the resolution condemning Russia that
was put before the security Council was
drawn up jointly by Albania and by the
U.S in defense of all countries to have
the right to be safe from Invasion and
annexation
we are voting yes and in defense of the
world's Collective peace and security we
urge you to vote Yes to let us show
Putin the resolve of this Council in
response Russia sounded incredulous
tell me do you seriously expect Russia
to consider and support such a draft and
if not then it turns out that you are
intentionally pushing us to use the
right of the veto in order to then wax
lyrical about the fact that Russia
abuses this right
and so when the draft resolution was put
to the vote there was no doubt how
Russia would respond it's a permanent
member of the security Council with veto
power and it used it abstentions please
raise your hands but it's notable that
four other council members decided not
to support the resolution and instead to
abstain China Brazil Gabon and India
escalation of rhetoric or tension is in
no one's interest it is important that
pathways are found for a return to the
negotiating table
keeping in view the totality of the
evolving situation
India decided to abstain on the
resolution
after the meeting the U.S ambassador
told reporters she take the issue to a
vote of all 193 United Nations members
in the general assembly
right after the Russian invasion of
Ukraine when the general assembly voted
at the beginning of March 141 countries
voted to deplore Russia's actions
following the security Council vote and
the abstentions some will be asking
whether it's possible to reach that high
water mark again
James Bay's Al Jazeera of the United
Nations